let's go okay
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to Yo favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Rachel you don't
there's the singing mic to Mrs Griffin
[Music]
all right well welcome back to the
podcast I'm back with Rachel we're
starting from the beginning with Rachel
because uh you know she said she loves
Marvel movies
so we watched a Marvel movie we watched
Iron Man and she's gonna review it so
welcome back
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so welcome back to the podcast
you can take the headphones off now if
you want all right just make sure you're
talking to the mic no like how
oh you do okay well fine you like having
them on Rachel likes having the
headphones on so we'll keep the
headphones on okay so welcome back to
riffing with Griffin starting from the
beginning riffing with the Griffins
maybe the new working title I don't know
if we're going to keep Rachel on by
popular demand uh but Rachel's back and
how you doing babe I'm doing well thanks
for having me on three weeks in a row
it's an honor it's an honor it's a
pleasure it is why are you talking in
your podcast voice babe just be you this
is me
oh by the way you have on a beautiful
dress today you look very nice two
shades of pink yeah two shades of pink
uh you know you look very handsome
yourself thank you very much thank you
uh thanks to you one of the shirts that
you bought me
you're not wearing your new glasses is
there a reason no I just I grabbed the
glasses from the the the side you know
when I get up I just I have two pairs of
glasses and I just grab one I don't
think about which one is which okay
I know you like the other ones better
I'll try to remember to wear those no
it's not that I like them better it's
just they're newer so it's like so you
like them better no I just want you to
wear what we bought together we didn't
buy them together yeah we did buy we
were in Beverly Hills we bought those
together
um yeah what are the what are they
what's the name of the cursor person
yeah I've never had any personals
uh they're nice
yeah shout out to persol they're very
nice glasses
um you know I if there's any other
glasses companies want to send me
glasses because I get my and I get my
lenses from this like online lens
company it's pretty good you just send
the glasses you like you like do the
order and you send the glasses and then
they come you know they send you you
know you get in with the prescription
and it's pretty you know pretty
reasonable price and it's pretty quick
um
yeah
you just keep looking at your notes well
I wanted to make sure my phone was on so
they were ready to go you know you're
not supposed to
Rachel accepted the challenge of I said
to her
because like last week she was talking
about oh I watch Marvel movies I love
Marvel movies you're never watching with
me so I was like all right let's watch a
Marvel movie then you'll review it you
know and so like she helped me till then
she was like when are we watching the
movie so you know and then I I told her
the first like because what do you like
to do you like to she likes to Google
stuff so what did you first Google
what is the best Marvel movie ever
and like black panther came up which I
completely disagree it was number one on
Rotten Tomatoes and had the highest
review of all Marvel movies and so I was
like let's watch this one and you were
like you gave me that weird attitude
yeah so I went to the second best Iron
Man you still had a weird no no reaction
my reaction was simply because it's
interesting that it's Iron Man because
literally Iron Man is basically the
first movie that starts the MCU you know
what the MCU is okay so that explains a
lot because that's why I never actually
started Marvel movies because I never
knew where to start oh that's the reason
yeah because it's like I don't want to
spoil something that happened because
everyone's like oh you can't watch this
until you watch that yeah that makes
sense and so then I never really knew
where to start and I figured one day
someone will teach me all right well
here we are you know what we're going to
start this adventure together and we're
starting with Iron Man and it was a
great start okay so we so I now know why
it's number two on Rotten Tomatoes it's
so good guys everyone needs to watch it
I don't even believe you right now but
we'll get to we're gonna we're gonna get
to the Iron Man review but first we're
just gonna like you know uh recap our
week and then and then you know because
uh here's a big thing that's coming up
uh Halloween's coming up and so Rachel
is that's one of her favorite holidays
and so she's like got got our costumes
together right so what are we gonna be
this year I'm not
costume they will see costumes I will be
on the episode right and I will have a
cameo and we'll show her costumes and it
will be great
okay I guess we're I guess we're doing
it that way
I think that's the best way you want to
ruin it and spoil well you just said the
cutest you just said the cutest silliest
joke that I wanted to like you to say on
the on the thing but I guess we'll wait
for uh we'll wait shout out to my buddy
uh Tyler Osteen in uh in Florida his I
think his uh boyfriend makes these
candles called centolts wait what is
this Santa Claus oh what a name
sentacles and this is uh you know from
they well I don't know just a shout out
to them
[Laughter]
um
all right well then since we're not
going to do our we're we're excited
because we're going to go to my buddy
Adam Ray's wedding in Arizona we talked
about that last week but we can't give
any details no no dude are you right
look at you all over it right now damn I
just I had a big podcast day because I
just went and did King and a sting and
it's like I don't know if I can change
the name I don't know what they're doing
but you know we just I just we did that
podcast that's way out in Calabasas and
now I'm home now with with uh you you
got yourself ready which is nice and uh
I guess we're um you know I don't know
we're ready to go do you want to say
anything about this past week what would
you anything that sticks out for you for
this past week nope
that's why I was asking you
we
uh I don't know I guess we're pretty
boring married couple now huh yeah we
work and we sleep and we eat
[Laughter]
we work we sleep and we eat I don't know
and then we repeat did you know what do
you think about here's something I'll
ask you about I don't know if you saw
this in the news but did you see how Ray
J was mad at Kim Kardashian because oh
yeah I did see that that was very
interesting yeah he's mad because she
was like I think because you I don't you
watch the Hulu show so apparently on the
Hulu show she's sort of inferred that
like he did something to her while she
was asleep
you know she said on the show something
about he put something in her butt while
she was asleep oh I've never heard that
one it was like the
is that on the first episode
spoiler alert
she or like her son
finds or is playing like Roblox and then
season ad for uh
came up again yeah and so then I read
that they were like
um in actuality Kim and her mom actually
own the rights to the videos and so they
actually he was saying that they
released it okay so what do you think
about that what do you think about like
like because then she did a lie detector
test one question okay let me finish
though she the mom Kris Jenner took a
lie detector test that she had nothing
to do with yeah that she had nothing to
do with it do you believe the lie
detector test you think she's smart
enough to fool the lie detector test
um I mean maybe so you don't think she
had anything to do with
because here's what I think okay
Kim Kardashian is a grown ass woman okay
and I think that she did this and then
she probably she if she could have went
to her mom and been like Mom I I did
something I did this I made this tape
you know and then this company is gonna
buy it
and then at that point do you think her
mom was like well if you're if it's
going to be out there let's make sure
you get the best deal
like that's a possibility like what do
you think about if that's the
possibility what do you think of that
it explains a lot of like why they're
trying to promote it on the show
I mean that's that's you I mean so what
I'm saying is like I mean it creates
controversy it creates people talking
like us even talking about it no I know
but what I'm saying though is like
there's some people that think like that
the mom's a monster that she you know
she's a businesswoman okay so that's
that's yours so men like to look at
business women as monsters that's fine
and there it is Fair Point okay if it
was a guy who did it to a guy then it
would just be a smart manager okay so
you think that if a father so you think
okay so I'm the father and my son comes
to my my in my 20s son comes to me and
he says Dad I made this sex tape and
this company wants to pay us this amount
of money and she's fine as [ __ ]
you would be like let's promote it let's
put it on the show let's re-release it
how would they say it
foing like f-o-i-n
okay all right and so you you think that
so you're saying you think that society
would just be like oh that's the that's
just a dad looking out for his kid so so
the reverse of that you're saying that
it should be okay for the mom to be like
make sure her daughter looks good in the
best light
I would hope so I feel so you're so we
have a daughter
and in 20 years our daughter is like hey
Mom Dad I I don't be mad but I made this
sex tape with we would be like this you
need to sign up for only fans you need
you need a
uh I I I I this is very interesting to
hear probably won't even exist then
maybe something else probably like
virtual reality or something like that
right but we would make sure she's on
the right
okay here's the thing I don't think the
dad would want to be involved or even
know about
because I think that's that would be
creepy or weird it would be weird if the
dad's like all right let me see all
three sex tapes I mean well let's even
put it in like say it was Britney
Spears's dad doing it to her
oh interesting
and all of a sudden it's like oh he's
just
um well he already got vilified for what
all he was doing well right that
well maybe she's the villain then who
the mom yeah that's what I'm asking you
is what you don't have to I'm just
asking your honest opinion I mean how do
you feel about it like because there are
people out there who think this is the
worst thing in the world and you
shouldn't like I'm not defending Kris
Jenner in any way all I'm saying is I
understand
depending on at what point did she get
involved in it like if she orchestrated
the whole thing that's I think she's a
monster like if she went to her daughter
and be like you should make a sex tape
with him then I'm like I don't know like
that but I think it needed both of her
and Kim's approval in order to Eve and
maybe even Ray J's approval oh he had to
get he got money too he had to approve
he can't just be in you can't just use
his likeness without his approval so of
course he's approved of it too because
they got paid a lot of money but that's
why he was upset because now he has like
a family and stuff no no because they're
making it seem like he did something it
was all him or something well they're
making it seem like Kanye well in the
show like Kanye like acts like a
superhero and like right right like
saves the day like it vilified him like
he had to go over there and give me that
computer you know yeah and he like came
back to the Kardashians he's like I got
it and I paid money and I won you know
and then they're like here's the
computer yeah thank you Kanye it was
like that it actually was like that but
but this is what I'm saying he later
wait let me see if I can find it because
he later uh was he later was talking
about it he was saying like
um
you know uh that she would say he wanted
to sue her for defamation because he was
saying she was saying on the show that
um
you know he
he like like feels like maybe he did
something to her while she was asleep
and which is assault so he was like hey
you don't I got kids now don't be acting
like I did I was the villain in this
whole thing we both were involved in
this you know but anyways my real thing
I wanted to ask you about was just about
like you know like if you we want to be
parents and like you know and what what
role should any parent play in the you
know monetization of their you know
kid or you know if there are if they're
a grown ass adult I maintain this I
think it's about the timeline like I am
totally against this if Kris Jenner
actually orchestrated the whole thing if
she like encouraged her hey go make a
sex tape with him then I'm like yeah but
like if her daughter who's a grown ass
woman comes to her mom because they have
that kind of relationship and she goes
hey Mom I know you're not gonna like
this but I made a sex tape and this
company wants to buy what do you think
and then if the mom was like I can't
believe you did this but
you know what you did it so let's let's
get the best out of it I don't know if I
think I'm okay with that
yeah I could see her being like let's
look at the contracts let's negotiate
yeah but but would you want to look at
the tapes would you want to make sure
it's the best one like what what do you
do you think that's weird for the mom to
be like you know all right let's look at
all of them okay yeah I didn't even
think of that like would they like what
if you agree to like release the tapes
you know to this a company and then they
decide to re-edit it how they want and
then you weren't well I mean that's
different I mean at that point if you're
giving them the rights to the movie they
could do whatever they want with it but
what I'm saying is I say there's three
tapes and you're only going to give them
one of them how do you decide which one
would you want like what's so funny
about this is your mom would never do
this
I would be like Mom I mean the sex tape
um which one do you think I should
release I mean it just
should be like you you need to get a
lawyer you need to she would be like I
don't know this she'd take you right to
Temple
I was like I don't
go find someone who knows this stuff
well that's that's fair I mean you
wouldn't want to see that nobody would
want to see that but I'm just saying
like I don't know where it is in the
timeline I'm just saying like would like
you know if Kris Jenner actually looked
at these tapes well if you actually like
I did read that there's like there are
three different tapes yeah and
um they acknowledged like what one was
what
and so but I'm saying do you think that
it was what kind of feeling do you get
if the mom was later now involved in
the business the contracts making sure
which tape went out if she orchestrated
that part of it what do you think about
that I'm I'm fine with it she's she's if
she has that kind of relationship with
her daughter yeah and she does and yeah
she obviously does because it turned
into a billion dollar business
[Laughter]
I answered the question other than like
she's supporting her daughter all right
all right because there's people out
there who like feel this stuff because
people didn't feel a certain way about
it like you know they're you know I I
like I say like I don't know like I
think like as a man like that wants to
be a dad I you know I don't know how I
would feel about that like I don't you
know you know what I mean like if my
wife like because she was single at the
time too but like like if you come to me
and be like hey you know whatever our
daughter's gonna name is if uh you know
Jeannie Ray whatever it is
she oh my God
whoever the name is we'll do a poll what
the name should be if our daughter if
you come to me and go hey she did
something and I'd be like what well she
made the sex tape and there's this
company there's money involved I'm gonna
take care of it I'm gonna go you make
sure you know you know if it's all about
money and business then yeah because
there's another side of it too where
their parents could just could be
totally like no I do not want you
putting that out do not do that this is
a bad idea and then you're daughter just
makes the choice on her own because
she's a grown ass woman I mean that's
the thing so the great the question is
like how do you feel about the parents
involvement you know
I think it's fine Eric okay I just want
to make sure all right I think it's it
shows a lot of
of like Kim to like want her parents to
be involved yeah okay you know what I
want to tell you I agree with you I feel
like because if I was that Mom I would
appreciate her coming to me instead of
finding out a different way right right
right right right right I guess that's
another way to look it's like how
supportive do you want to be you know
that I get it you know it just I mean it
just is what it is you know family is
supposed to be your like support system
your backbone so if you couldn't come to
those people that that would be sad yeah
I agree look at you all right one topic
down here's another one okay you
remember that girl uh what's her name uh
she was on Dr Phil you know catch me
outside whatever her name is little baby
or a baby something or a baby boo or I'm
so I feel so old right now uh let me let
me Google it on my phone catch me
outside girl what's her name she's like
a rapper now and apparently she proves
that she made 50 million dollars on only
fans
um
you know you know that did you hear
about that how so by just being
provocative yeah yeah probably yeah
what's her name bad baby so you're just
telling people to go check her out no I
mean Rachel people already know I don't
know I just saw this art this is not
what I'm what I'm why I'm bringing it up
I'm bringing it up because she uh I
believe that Harvard
is asking her to come here we go the
cash me outside woman has been invited
to speak at Oxford okay uh Oxford is the
college one of the most prestigious
colleges in the world that's in England
I believe and you know she's now 19. her
name's Daniella so she start you know so
she started rapping and doing all this
stuff and making it only fans account
she made all this money and it's like
you know it's like what do you think
about this really prestigious School
having her come speak
I think it's just a place to get her
word out and
um they want to offer that
tour so that's great I think everyone
um should be able to tell their story
and if it's at a prestigious School cool
if it's on a podcast that's cool too you
know it's well you know what I you know
it's again I think we're on the same
page because I was thinking about it's
like so there is a element of people
thinking like you know whether you have
this like you know she was on only fans
and like she was so ratchet on like in
her beginning in her early years but
then I started to think to myself all
right so what's the real story when you
step back and look at the picture so
here's a girl that had a tough start
obviously not the greatest home
environment because that's why she was
acting like that and was on Dr Phil
anyway right because she was like crazy
like you know just acting up and then
she got her got it together you know she
she's like she monetized all of her um
what do you call it attention you know
likability attraction attractiveness and
she monetized all that and turned it
into like a turned into a mogul and so
now she wants to go Oxford's like hey
come speak at our college and talk to
other people about your journey so it's
like it's really about like how we feel
about like what people do like you know
sex work and things like that like uh
and here she is like you know become
this business Mogul that made 50 million
dollars let's see what she does with it
uh next it's just it just was like weird
I didn't know how I felt about it my
initial thing was like what and then I
thought like well look what she did it's
not easy like if everybody can make 50
million dollars on only fans we'd all be
doing it well it's a whole lifestyle
choice you know only fans because it's
like you have to like think like okay
this is gonna be on the internet people
could like
I mean you're not supposed to but people
could record it on a different phone
through the phone so it's like it's
gonna be out there and so you have to be
okay with it and you have to like know
that you can't get a normal job after
that because like No One's Gonna hire
you knowing that they could just Google
your naked stuff and I mean I've heard
stories where people have to quit their
jobs because their bosses find out
they're on only fans oh wow and I mean
it's fine because they're making so much
money that they don't care about their
other jobs but like you have to make
that choice and for me I wouldn't do it
because
the type of career I'm trying to get
yeah I get totally get that here's
another thing that she did too is like
she also she launched a 1.7 million
dollar scholarship fund it's a
non-profit Educational Foundation which
she sees a thousand trade school
students give a thousand dollar
scholarships for their education so like
you know what I mean like she's doing
like so she's doing communities or not
community service like uh giving back
she's doing a community service and
she's giving back to the community so
it's like it's very uh I guess it
doesn't matter where you start is about
what you do with it in the end I don't
know it's just like that now what do you
guys feel about it on in the comments
and stuff what do you think about uh
what do you think about her going to
Oxford can you can you divorce yourself
from what you remember of her all the
negative stuff they showed about her and
what do you think about her now as like
a young entrepreneur you know she
monetized all this and turned it into a
little Empire for herself and now she's
trying to give back like what do you
think about it all right all right uh
thank you Rachel for your thoughts on
that here's more your thoughts but
because I didn't I don't even know much
about well that's why I asked you about
it I just thought about it because I
here's the thing I was normally gonna do
my podcast normal yeah I don't know much
about anything you just asked me the
last two topics the only two topics we
talked about I have no idea so yeah but
you want the Kardashians you watched you
mean you lost you forced me to watch the
Kardashians yeah but I don't like
research the Kardashians I think you do
I didn't I think you did well next time
when I before a pre-topic like you I'll
have you like yeah that would be nice
I'll let you be prepared like you are
for this next topic thank you because I
like to be prepared I I see that now
okay so now we know moving forward on
the riffing with Griffins we need topic
approval
by me
okay so last week as you know Rachel
claims she likes Marvel movies and like
I don't watch him with her because she
normally doesn't like violence and
Adventure stuff but okay people change
so we sat down and we watched Iron Man
so this is Rachel's Iron Man review
Rachel take it away what did you think
of Iron Man first okay overall I loved
it I thought it was a great movie from
beginning to end I cried I laughed I you
cried every emotion like usual when it's
a good movie and so please you cry when
it's a bad movie it doesn't have to be a
good movie you still cry okay well it
gave me those those emotions and so I
appreciate it okay so uh in your okay
for you so tell me what Iron Man was
about okay
here we go
first he was just this guy
what's his name what's his name the
owner of Stark Industries
okay let me Tony start let me look at my
notes guys
this is why I make notes okay and he was
played by Robert Downey Jr oh wow you
really think she uh I didn't know who
that was I was like is that Tom Hanks is
that
is that Uma Thurman
I'm and then it was
um Gwyneth Paltrow as pepper and his
assistant she oh my god I didn't even
know she was in this right to be honest
I know Gwyneth Paltrow just off goop
oh yeah she even the sex show is about
yeah
we're gonna talk about goop next week
but go on Enzo Iron Man sing
little Cameo at first I was like oh my
God it wasn't a cameo she was
the second to best character or she was
the best character in my opinion but
like really Pepper Potts was the best
character in the movie not Iron Man not
Tony Stark she killed it she now I know
why she has a goof as her Empire I
understand she's so great she okay okay
she I took it as like she she blew her
part out of the water because like
instead of thinking of the movie as like
acting like it became real she like made
it more real like he was so let's go on
about what the movie was about okay so
Tony Stark go on he owned this company
that made weapons for the government
okay and he made this giant
missiles okay and he got famous for it
and so like people around the world
um saw his missiles and they were like
we need those missiles and so
um basically the guy that also works for
Tony Stark
what's his name I don't even remember
his name he's important character but he
said he was it was the second hand guy
that was you know helping him run the
company yeah he was like he sent him on
this trip and he knew what he was doing
but you don't find that out till later
okay and then spoiler alert by the way
also by the way I'm not that great at
telling back things in the right order
so
I love this this is what we wanted to do
you you were doing the Iron Man review
with Rachel Griffin but go on okay so
Tony's okay what happened now okay so
they sent him to what is it Afghanistan
or something like that someplace like
that and um and he gets like put in a
cave he gets captured
well okay they blow up all the military
people they capture him and then they
make him build
the missile that he's famous for in
Stark Industries and so he's like
he he is there captured in the cave with
another guy who's really smart and he
can translate for him
yeah and so he translates everything
that the villains are saying and they're
like you need to build this missile
otherwise they're gonna kill us and so
he was like I'm not gonna build no
missile for these
those people that's how you said it okay
well he was more like I'm not gonna do
that nope
that's your that's your Tony Stark voice
yeah okay okay it did and then
um the guy his the other guy in there
he's this smart guy I wish he lived more
than he did but he was like go spoiler
alert this guy dies go on yeah
he was like use your power
you could if you're gonna die tomorrow
do something about you know do prove
something I know I think but you skipped
a whole thing there but go on really
yeah
because he's in the cave and what
happens in the cave for some reason he
is clean
he's well shaven
he has fresh clothes like a how it's a
cave okay all right all right I like
that but instead he instead of building
a missile he tricks them and secretly
Builds an Iron Man suit and oh before
that though the uh the smart guy right
it he like under he's like a doctor or
surgeon too yeah yeah the guy was a
doctor and so he was like after he got
captured he realized he was gonna die
and so he fixed him and he put this
thing in his heart to like what what
there's this liquid and like bugs or
something in his body it was an
electromagnet because they were shrapnel
in his heart what's it called shrapnel
from the bone yeah and so then he looks
like ants yeah but he was like he but
it's like metal right so he was like so
the magnet kept it from going in his
heart okay and so it was like a can of
soup type mechanism okay and so he used
that can of soup
liquid what's it called retinol no the
shrapnel no no that's what he did so he
didn't create anything in there to say
help power remember all that no I have
no idea what you're talking about okay
so we'll just get past that just get
past that so the Iron Man is important
the Iron Man suit was powered by soup
well the heart can't the heart can
powered it okay
and he was able to this Mark I was able
to distract the people long enough to
get uploaded smartness into his suit
and uh and then he was able to have
superhuman strength and airplane power
and he used that to shoot that that
sound was him shooting out of his hand
he had I think the people had throwers
out of the hands and the feet okay and
that was his that's his suit's
superpower okay because most most Marvel
movies like Superman Batman Spider-Man
they have a superpower okay hold on let
me stop you right there so Marvel you
said Superman Batman Spiderman is that
right uh yeah okay
Superman is not Marvel nor is Batman
that's actually DC
totally different universe so you're
saying Marvel doesn't have super powers
they have
just suit Powers no I'm not saying that
Iron Man just has suit Powers but
Superman and Batman are in a whole
different Universe okay well forget
about those people
and we're gonna go back to this suit
okay that has powers and really if you
think about it it's brain Powers by that
smart guy
so you think it wasn't Tony Stark it was
the other guy well it's both because
Tony Stark actually
I mean I don't know if you know this
about me but I went to school for
mechanical engineering yeah for five
years I know this about you okay and
um it really impressed me that they made
this character uh like a Gearhead you
know kind of like someone who Tony Stark
yeah who's smart enough to like build
cars to build engines to build like
these missiles and like that's what like
got my attention from the start of
because
they show
um his garage
and like
his machines okay well let's stay on
topic with the movie because you're
still doing your recap okay so they're
in the cave he's got the suit he's flew
into flamethrowers
he kills them all and flies away and
he realizes his suit can only go so far
up in the universe and so the universe
kind of kills his suit and because they
didn't make it strong enough because he
didn't know
because this is his first time building
the suit you know he was just trying to
escape
and so the atmosphere kills the suit he
falls to the ground ends up in the
desert and then a miracle
walking for five minutes and a miracle
happens with the miracle military from
the United States come and fly over him
and he waves them down they see him they
see him and come right maybe they saw
the the the thing fly and fall they saw
the explosion maybe maybe that's how
they found him maybe okay so all right
then what happens okay let me think then
um
babe then they take him back and they
like give him a superhero or award for
like being alive and
um today there was an award in there
yeah I think they gave him an award
they're okay he wasn't there
but the other guy took the award okay
that was in the beginning of the movie
in the in the back story of before he
went to the cave okay
not when he was rescued but yeah I mean
same thing
it doesn't really matter that order we
just know just know that okay so then
okay so he's back okay and then then
what happens
and then the he was like
I've been trauma
I am no longer
a weapon come
I am going to make peace with the Middle
East
[Laughter]
and I am going to transform this company
into something that helps instead of
deconstructs okay then what happened the
the so far so good the VP guy was like
uh-uh
this is a weapons company and you are
about to kill our stock and of course
stock goes down uh-huh they take him out
they're like you no longer run this
company right we're taking over we have
people and
um
and goodbye and so they so Tony Stark
was like
upset at first
but then he was like you know what I'm
gonna go to my garage I'm gonna build
that suit and even better and I'm gonna
show them uh-huh
what kind of company this is got you so
I mean it's a Soup company
so he's making his Brook Brothers now
it's a suit company and okay pepper is
his right hand woman and every time she
comes in he's like
thank you
thank you pepper uh-huh actually I
really like that name pepper we might go
with a p name
pepper Griffin yeah
salt pepper so pepper Griffin
Peppers here
okay anyway all right so he's making
he's now a suit company so what does he
do
and his heart wasn't working to the
potential he could make it and so he had
pepper re put in the heart can of soup
and
basically she was like ew gross but then
did it and then liked it
and then I think that bonded them even
more to be honest
yeah this is great this is great because
I this is like you saw a completely
different movie than me really yeah okay
but go on this is great okay so uh the
heart has been changed with the soup it
is nasty she liked it he's making a Soup
company and then and then
um and then War breaks out somewhere and
oh no the VP guy sells the missiles to
the villains for some reason right well
probably for money reasons yeah and also
the people the villain people were like
really upset because they were like
um Tony Stark disappeared and
and you know they didn't get their
missiles right he was supposed to make
the missile for him and he didn't he
made the suit he escaped and now so the
VB gave him their missiles yeah the BP
his name was Jebediah I believe and
um then Tony Stark was like I told you I
wasn't gonna give those missiles and
we're not a missile company anymore
right so he put on his suit uh-huh from
his new suit company uh-huh learned his
superpowers which were like
um airplane
um flying airplane stuff like he could
levitate a little he could fly he could
shoot out flames and so he realized
well you know he had he he did this type
of testing with us yes and it kind of
made it more real you know like he
wasn't I totally agree with you it
wasn't like all sudden yeah yeah he knew
his superpowers he knew how to do
everything he like we were brought along
this journey yeah yeah training to be
the best and it made it seem real yeah I
totally agree with you okay now we're on
the same page that Montage of him
learning how to that all made it like oh
this could be possible that was great
filmmaking but go on
yeah and so he learned his powers and he
flew out of nowhere and just arrived at
the missiles
saved everyone in the town at that point
because they were this boy was gonna he
was gonna miss his dad and they took the
dad away and they're you know they were
gonna kill the dad and so he saved him
just in time of course right and blew up
the missile blew up everyone let the
community take charge of the
yeah and then flew back and then but on
his way back America they were like it's
American Shield you know something like
that and so Amir the you know military
was getting involved and they're like
that's not us that's you know someone
else right and then they're like wait is
it us and then the military guy that's
like best friends with Stark Joe John
what is this Tony
yeah Tony okay he called him and he was
like where are you and he's like oh
nowhere but you could hear like him
flying but he was like oh it's in I'm in
my car and then they he reveals that
it's actually him flying and he got to
kind of keep it a secret but he was like
oh like don't kill that guy and so
American like military they couldn't
even get him anyway yeah and Iron Man
suit's pretty good so they end up coming
back and the military guy had to be like
sorry we were testing that's what they
say when like they accidentally kill
someone
and
and
so that's how you know then Tony had to
do a press conference and be like
I'm not
Iron Man but then he was like I am
though
that was a little confusing at that
conference that was at the end of the
movie you skipped the whole yeah it
wasn't it was no yeah no no
it was right in the middle you skipped
the whole fight so you come one fight
okay never mind this is your review go
ahead thank you
um so out of the presence conference he
he like used his like masculinity of
like I need to tell them I'm the hero
okay
you think that was a mistake mistake
okay
yeah what happened oh I forgot the whole
thing that he slept with the interviewer
girl that was way in the beginning of
the movie oh my God I can't believe I
forgot that
super womanizing movie
okay
I'm so disappointed in Marvel that they
even like made that type of character to
be like oh she's hot I'll take the
interview but
that's when we see his Malibu mansion
right or it wasn't a mansion it was like
yes oh my God or something it was
everyone's fantasy house yeah so don't
you don't you understand why the
reporter went to his place then
yeah I mean I would go yeah okay so but
that's nice that's a little hypocritical
okay anyway there's no gloss over there
well that's when you first see his house
okay Mansion uh-huh
um and that's when you realize like oh
this guy is like
he has everything you know and so
when he sleeps with the interviewer
you're kind of like thinking well is she
gonna like write about him negatively is
she going to like exploit him is she
going to be his love interest
okay but Pepper made it very clear she
was like I'm taking out the trash and
you are the trash
so please gather your stuff and
please leave
so you this is all out of order but
that's fine it's your recap yeah
[Laughter]
yeah okay so then what happened okay
okay so let's go back so then during the
press conference where we were the
interviewer lady was there and she's
like yeah that's how he revealed that he
was Iron Man because she was like
inferring and then whatever and then
what
and then pepper was like I'm not gonna
help you be Iron Man because you're
gonna die
um
and then he was like
I need you and then he shows up to this
party and she's in this amazing dress
and her hair and makeup are perfect and
she does this turn she goes uh
and he sees her at that point and he
falls in love he's like he helped my
heart she helped my heart I don't even
know if we watched the same movie but
come on she's given looks okay you know
she has her Louboutins uh -huh and she
gets later you see her walking with her
red bottoms on glass yeah okay
like that's real but
that's how she got goop for sure
okay and so then what okay anyway
so after the press conference
he um the other guy the VP guy decides
that he is also going to make the Iron
Man suit okay and
um fight Iron Man and uh he goes to iron
at Tony Stark's house and kind of was
like he's shocked he like well first he
goes to the villains country and like
uses that
weird technology weird technology that
freezes them that they can't move for 15
minutes and so it gets rid of them yeah
and then
he does the same thing to Tony and
okay and then gets all his like suit
information
plans okay and then takes it back to the
warehouse and tells his people from
Stark Industries to build this for him
and they're like oh we can't because it
doesn't work properly right and then he
had to figure out like oh that metal Tin
Can that's in his chest that's what
powers it okay and so he that's why he
stuns the guy and takes his heart the
guy Tony Tony yeah and and then Tony was
like he needed to go down to his office
and he he had Pepper's gift which was
the old one the old heart yeah and he
was like I gotta put this in and for
some reason he couldn't do it himself
the first two times but all sudden now
he was able to take it out and put it in
himself this is plot holes with Rachel
that didn't make sense very much but
like we went with it we went with it
pepper shows up she's like oh my God let
me help uh-huh and then
happily ever after all right the end huh
let me think about it
um okay just overall you enjoyed the
movie yeah you enjoyed the movie and it
was for you it was a nice love story oh
yeah and then I watched like behind the
scenes stuff and I learned some stuff so
let me tell you what I learned okay okay
so
the director executive producer John
yeah he was in the movie yeah that's
what I was about to say he was the
driver in the movie and he
and he yeah that was really interesting
yeah because if I were to make a well
first of all I would love to be in a
Marvel movie all right put it out there
put that energy out there you could be
the the superhero oh okay and then I'll
be your love interest uh-huh obviously
I mean how could you resist me
how could I be yeah I mean or I'll be
the superhero and you'll be my love
interest okay that could work too yeah
okay so
that's number one or
um
what else I would want to like I would
love to make my own superhero movie okay
because
that's why he made this movie because
that
um Iron Man was his favorite yeah so
that's why he was so passionate about it
and that's why it's so good yeah and it
started and it started a whole franchise
of movies okay I also learned that
um for the suit there was multiple
people involved like there was a suit
consultant okay there was an illustrator
of the suit there was an animator of the
suit there was a storyboard artist for
the suit there was the cad artist 3D
animation of this suit and there were
multiple suits in like like Tony Stark
actually made multiple suits in the
movie like three suits right I don't
know
and then they made four whatever and
anyways I thought that was really
interesting that there were so many
people involved in just like one part of
it all right so like overall I'm hearing
from you that you really enjoyed Iron
Man well and okay this is also very
interesting to me that
they wanted to give the superhero
um
like a West Coast
representation because most Marvel
superheroes are on the East Coast like
New York I did not know that
well that you're welcome
because I I was like they kept bringing
up that their Studios like that they
built all the sets were in Playa Vista
and I'm like oh that's really close to
here yeah you know and I was like that's
interesting and then they're like well
first it started like filming in
Hollywood and then like in Beverly Hills
at the Marvel Studios and then they all
just like and then like the suit was
built in Van Nuys and so it was all like
this West Coast and you're a Cali girl
really loved that yeah that really like
brought interest more interesting so are
we gonna watch so so now you want to
watch in order now of all the Marvel
movies uh you know well I mean next I'm
definitely gonna watch Iron Man 2.
okay that's that's probably yeah I think
we're done with Iron Man no I'm not done
I have a whole list of other things been
like we're we're out of time
[Laughter]
you recapped the whole movie you went
into all the things so pick a couple of
things that you that that you really
enjoyed because we're just getting I'm
just getting a sense that Rachel really
enjoyed the movie She recapped it those
that have seen the movie uh I don't know
if you uh you know I mean we missed the
whole fight scene but that's fine
foreign
oh I forgot to bring up the most
important part what's that
how many coffees and espressos did this
guy drink during the movie
because it was non-stop it was like that
was pepper that's what you noticed
pepper was basically a latte artist
she was the love interest and she was a
barista yeah I wonder what kind of milk
well one time they actually showed the
coffee and it was just black coffee but
I wonder if I also had a green drink
that one time remember oh yeah that was
very important that gave him energy so
overall how many woo-woos would you give
Iron Man
all right y'all this has been ripping
with the Griffins Rachel's recap of Iron
Man uh if you haven't seen it maybe go
watch it and look at the things that
she's talking about in it but I'm glad
you you actually it sounds like you
really enjoyed it yeah and thank you for
watching it with me yeah that also made
the experience like 50 times better
love it so guys thanks for being here
just uh make sure you subscribe like
share hit me on Twitch Eric Griffin
gaming check me out there check me out
on uh patreon or if you want to be a
member you could be a subscriber on
Twitch a member on uh YouTube any which
way you'd like to support the show
that's away also follow me you can
follow Rachel at uh she's still Rachel
Instagram on Instagram on Tick Tock okay
I'll put on I'll put all your links
below babe all your links will be below
YouTube as well well
thank you very much thank you this is
abandon Rachel Griffin I'm Eric Griffin
this has been riffing with Griffin and
we will see you next time see you next
time bye
yeah I love you love you too man